eating for daylight savings
what
hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
today we'll be looking at another
harper's bizarre food diaries of the
beautiful and talented academy award
winner catherine zeta jones but first
let me tell you about my sponsor nordvpn
so like everyone else i spend a lot of
time online both for work and also for
pleasure so naturally i'm really
cognizant about keeping my online
property safe so nordvpn is a powerful
tool for keeping users safe while
browsing online anywhere anytime on any
and all devices
it's super easy to use and connects with
one simple click and allows you to
connect to the fastest of their 5200
servers around the world
and it really is fast they're actually
the fastest vpn on the market this is
also so amazing for traveling when
you're not in the comfort of your own
home because you can access streaming
platforms from anywhere in the world by
just changing your virtual location
so even if a movie or show that you want
to watch isn't available at home like
the great british bake off for me
you can still get access to it with
nordvpn it also encrypts all your
traffic so your internet service
provider can't slow down your streaming
speed so since so many of us are
continuing to spend a lot of time at
home and socialize through things like
zoom and online games now is a great
time to invest in a great vpn so if you
want to check nordvpn out go to
nordvpn.com
abby sharp or use my promo code abby
sharp to get a two year plan plus four
additional months with a huge discount
all right back to the video first a
quick reminder to look at my disclaimer
on screen and in the description below
including a trigger warning to those
struggling with disordered eating as
always i'm critiquing meals so feel free
to sit this one out if it's triggering
for you and again a reminder to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
little bell so that you never miss out
on an episode all right well i would say
that mrs jones needs no introduction
but if you feel she does well that's
what google is for but i will just say
that my favorite rolls of hers like a
toss-up between ocean's 12 and chicago
love me a good hearty musical but
anyways leave me a comment below with
your personal pick the 51 year old
british actress is now married to
michael douglas and she has a lot to say
about food so let's take a look first
thing i do when i wake up in the morning
is get my coffee going because i really
can't do anything properly without my
coffee so i get that brewing i usually
put it into a french press because
there's something very nostalgic about
that yes i would say french press is
super nostalgic if you've traveled
abroad a lot you are old enough to
remember time pre-starbucks or you are a
millennial hipster who
argues over the merits of french press
versus pour over with your friends but
anyways in any case i don't critique
coffee so however you want to brew it it
works for me i get up very early so my
house is super quiet and it's my little
time just to be girl i feel you on that
you know when i became a parent i was
introduced to this awful dilemma where
you basically have to choose between
quiet alone time or getting a possible
amount of sleep but definitely you can't
have both and katherine is a lot older
than me so
sadly i now see that this does not
change i don't usually eat breakfast
until about eight o'clock
i like to have breakfast i'm a three
meals a day kind of girl but i do have
very very specific breakfast needs and
it's all about daylight saving i feel
like all the young intermittent fasting
wellness influencers are shocked that
somebody put calories in their body
before noon never mind as early as 8 00
a.m well if you really want to rock your
world watch my 4 a.m morning routine
right here catherine says that her
breakfast choices often change depending
on the time of year and like what the
weather is like or she calls it eating
around daylight savings i think if you
think about it
this is actually a really intuitive
practice that most of us are already
doing i'm not sure that all of us are so
intentional that like the moment that
the clocks spring forward or fall
backwards and it's like oh we gotta
clear out the pantry from all the
oatmeal and bring in the non-fat yogurt
but i would say a lot of us maybe don't
naturally crave a ton of super hot
hearty foods like stews or rich
casseroles in the summer
and we're less likely to gravitate
towards light cold foods like salads and
smoothies in the winter now research
suggests that not only is this totally
common and normal but it's actually one
of our body's adaptive strategies for
thermoregulation seasonal shifts in food
preferences can also help to improve
long-term macronutrient and
micronutrient balance so if we were to
eat rutabaga and potatoes 12 months of
the year or conversely live off of
watermelon and peaches
we would be missing out on
other micronutrients that other food
options have to offer so like i always
say variety is the spice of life
not just within a day or within a week
but even within the year as a whole in
the winter hours i'm a porridge girl i
have porridge with brown sugar bananas
and i make it so the bananas are all
soggy and full of brown sugar and i put
some blueberries on the top and i
literally have that
every morning when we spring forward
non-fat vanilla yogurt barenaked granola
blueberries
raspberries and that is my
summer month's go-to breakfast so in
katherine's case she suggests enjoying a
warm bowl of oatmeal with bananas and
brown sugar in the winter and yogurt
with granola and berries in the summer
both of which sound delicious to me i
think if she want to bump up the satiety
factor she could add a little protein
and fat to oats by maybe making my
proteins or just adding in lots of nuts
and seeds or nut butter and then going
for a higher protein yogurt like skir or
greek yogurt for her summer morning pick
i also would pretty much always opt for
higher fat yogurt over skim now i know
this is not the diet advice that you got
back in the 90s it's actually not even
the recommendation that i was taught
when i was in school wait a second maybe
it's that yogurt no no no that's 100
non-fat but i do
want to set the record straight and
explain why i recommend full fat so
first of all not only does fat increase
the satiety factor of your breakfast but
there's actually more to the story than
just that i have a whole blog post on
this which i'm going to link below but
in short
one meta-analysis found that dairy
consumption especially yogurt products
is associated with a reduced risk of
obesity another meta-analysis looking
specifically at dairy fat levels
concurred that dairy fat or higher fat
dairy consumption was inversely
associated with obesity risk and the
women's health study on almost 20 000
women over 11 years
they found that higher intakes of full
fat dairy but not low fat or fat free
dairy was associated with lower risk of
weight gain now we don't know for sure
why this is but it's very likely related
to higher amounts of unique components
in dairy fat like conjugated linoleic
acid butyric acid and palmitoleic acid
there's also other potential hormone
related benefits to higher fat dairy
products over lower fat dairy with early
research suggesting that higher fat
dairy may help to reduce the risk of an
ovulatory infertility while low-fat
dairy may actually increase it and some
research linking skim milk but not whole
milk to acne most importantly full fat
just tastes better but obviously if
non-fat dairy is genuinely what you
prefer which could totally be what's
going on with catherine here then i say
great i mean i think both are totally
fine options i just want to make sure
that we're not demonizing fat i think
we're kind of past that that's when we
as a family do a good british fry up i
get my imported british bacon we have
sausages which we call bangers we have
baked beans scrambled eggs we do french
toast brioche bread let it soak and then
of course good old canadian maple syrup
every weekend it comes together in a
fabulous family brunch oh my god can i
come to the family brunch okay so we got
lots going on here the full kahuna
whatever that means
what does that mean quite the spread uh
but we've got some carbs of course in
the french toast and maple syrup gotta
get the maple syrup we've got protein in
the eggs and beans fat in the breakfast
sausage and bacon sounds like a really
good time to me and yes this is a higher
fat higher sugar higher salt meal but i
do think that incorporating these kind
of more indulgent meals in the context
of a week that is packed with produce
packed with lots of naturally nourishing
foods is totally fair game life is too
short if she wanted to freshen this up i
would personally serve this with some
greek yogurt and berries for the french
toast and i'd probably do some either
roasted tomatoes and mushrooms or even
like a side salad for the more savory
breakfast but honestly i say in the
context of a diet like catherine's which
is rich in lots of other fruits and
veggies and things like that i say a
little weekend brunch fun is totally
fine next is 11 o'clock i always have a
cup of tea and usually have a
cookie or something i'm not a big
snacker except for anything chocolate
for me chocolate is a real treat i
deserve it i like cadbury's milk
chocolate because again it's a british
brand that i was brought up with and
it's very comforting okay so i just want
to flag that i know there's this popular
trope that suggests you deserve certain
foods like sweets often for doing
something that you don't like doing like
exercise now i like that katherine
didn't assign like a transaction to her
chocolate i just kind of want to clarify
since no one ever talks about carrots or
peas as something that they've earned or
deserved but i want you to know
that you deserve
to eat foods you enjoy hard stop and yes
even the less nutritious ones like milk
chocolate i am also all about adding
foods to your diet not taking them away
so i say if catherine wanted her cookie
or milk chocolate as her treat
but was looking for a little more
staying power to
get her to lunch i would want to think
about the hunger crushing combo
so for example she could have a cookie
or chocolate but pair it with maybe some
apple and almond butter or a slice of
toast smear with some ricotta and top
with some berries let's take a look at
lunch lunch i always sit down with to
lunch with my husband if we're not
working we're very big on family meals i
don't know whether it's my european
connection if the kids are here any
family members anybody who's in our
household we stop and we sit down and we
have lunch yes yes
yes
you guys have heard me wax poetic about
the importance of family meals and that
to me
how you eat is in a lot of cases even
more important for good health than what
you're eating but the evidence suggests
that family meals can improve diet
quality reduce the risk of disordered
eating drug and alcohol abuse
improve self-esteem and lower mental
health diseases
improve grades and communication for
kids reduce screen time and encourage
more mindful eating so even if the only
way to get together for a family meal is
by leaning on some convenience foods or
takeout i still think that that may beat
wolfing down some kind of meal prep
salad by yourself on the go and speaking
of salad lunch is usually a light affair
for us always a salad so my favorite
kind of salad would be
a spinach arugula mix of of leaves pine
nuts tomatoes i sometimes put a little
blue cheese i love blue cheese my
husband loves blue cheese and my
dressing extra virgin olive oil balsamic
vinegar i sometimes put some mustard in
there mix mix mix mix mix mix mix mix
mix shake and toss
this sounds amazing okay so i know i
just said that a fast food family burger
might be better than like a sad salad
inhaled in rush hour
but
of course it's a bonus when what you're
sitting down to as a family is also
nutrient dense and it sounds like
catherine has got this in the bag so
we've got lots of protein from the
chicken or cod loads of fiber rich veg
and some fat in the blue cheese and
extra virgin olive oil i would
definitely add a little carb in here
just to bump up the satiety and
satisfaction factor
even if it's just as simple as like a
little pita bread on the side but
otherwise this really does sound like a
really lovely meal in the afternoon i
always 4 30 i brew my cassada jones
coffee i love it because it's my blend
and it's the kind of coffee that i love
if i'm really really good i've already
baked some scones and clotted cream and
jam i also do
deeply love me a good scone with clotted
cream and jam
but i'm not really sure what catherine
meant by the statement
if i'm really good like was that a diet
culture reference suggesting that if she
has eaten healthfully enough that day or
like worked out hard enough that she
will have earned herself a scone
or was she just being like hey if i'm on
my a-game that day and doing all the
things i will have also have baked up a
batch of scones it seems like the latter
but you never really know with these
celebs but just in case you need a
reminder you do not i repeat you do not
need to be extra good to earn any kind
of food period let's try to separate our
moral standing from our food choices
like a scone is just fuel and we need
fuel
i need fuel delicious fuel especially
fresh like no one wants a day old scone
i think something should be said for
enjoying certain foods as is and like
not trying to healthify them and she did
describe having a lower carb lunch so it
does make sense to me that she might
want to enjoy a more carb forward snack
shortly after but if she did want to
give this afternoon snack like a little
more staying power she could serve it
with some chia jam i actually have a
really great recipe on my blog and a
nice full fat greek yogurt or maybe a
few hard-boiled eggs on the side let's
take a look at dinner so a typical
dinner for me would be my salad in this
salad at night i love fruit i
always chop up an apple throw it in a
salad of course i love avocado in a
salad too i would put oranges in my
salad figs in my salad i feel like
catherine and i are salad soul mates
and by that i mean that we could share
meals if we went out for dinner because
we probably would end up ordering the
same thing anyway i too
really like fruit in my salad and aside
from like greek salad and caesar salad
if it doesn't have some kind of sweet
element i'm just not into it salads to
me have got to be sweet salty crunchy
juicy bitter sour and chewy like it's
all about the contrast going on right
there yes i approve let's see what goes
with that salad so my perfect supper
probably would be i'm a big fish and
chicken white meat kind of girl but i do
love just a regular filament with like a
mushroom shiitake mushroom sauce and
then
vegetables clean
sauteed okay so i thought we were bosom
buddies but then she just used the c
word after which i kind of blacked out
what i assume she meant was that she
liked her veggies prepared simply with
just like a basic saute which assumes
maybe some kind of oil and seasoning
hopefully but just in case you need to
hear it again or in case catherine
herself needs a heads up i do hope that
all vegetables consumed are clean like
if they've been rinsed off before you
cook them or eat them raw
they're clean but anyways
this does sound like an awesome meal
we've got some lean protein in the fish
or white meat chicken
and honestly when it comes to beef
even filet mignon is a relatively lower
fat choice i know everyone always
obsesses over how much fat is in beef
but it really does come down to the cut
and a four ounce serving of filet mignon
has just 160 calories and 7.5 grams of
fat compared to 4 ounces of chicken
breast which has 110 calories and 2.5
grams of fat honestly
not a huge deal the calories really
shouldn't be the big reason to limit
your consumption of beef in my books i
think a lot of us can probably agree
that beef is one of the least
sustainable protein options seeing as
red meat production produces
significantly more co2 emissions and
requires far more land water fuel
fertilizer and pesticides compared to
poultry or other forms of protein
and also if you're choosing a lean cut
like tenderloin you're also dealing with
a bit of a financial splurge but
ultimately if you love steak and you can
afford an occasional splurge financially
know that at least nutritionally it is
not the devil as for environmental
considerations my general message is yes
we should probably all aim to eat meat
in moderation especially beef maybe it's
none of my business but if you eat three
pounds of steak every day you're gonna
die but i think it's more realistic to
try to inspire people to incorporate
more plants into their diet not
necessarily to swear off all animal
products for life if they really do
enjoy the occasional steak baby steps is
usually a little bit more tolerable for
people
anyways as a whole this meal does look
delicious
i would say that it's probably a pretty
low carb meal even with the bits of
fruit in the salad so i would say adding
in like a potato whole grain or even a
little baguette would round things out
really nicely if someone would say to me
what would be your final wish for meal
what i do love
is cauliflower cheese
i guess i'm a big cheese lover i love
cauliflower cheese a big cauliflower
flour cooked whole with
cheese sauce and melted cheese all over
it and that was like one of her
specialities that's something that it's
a little piece of home oh the way she
talks about food is so inviting she kind
of reminds me of nigella lawson not just
aesthetically but also in her sensual
descriptions of even the most mundane
simple foods but this actually sounds
amazing as a mom i am well versed on the
power of cheese sauce or cheese in
general okay i eat all the cheese i eat
all of the cheese at making plain jane
veggies way more exciting and inviting
for kids because i'm not sure if some of
my gen zed followers remember
but there was a time when cauliflower
wasn't cool like when it legit needed
its wingman velveeta to make it
appealing and edible but i do think that
cauliflower and cheese is like a combo
that will forever stand the test of time
and this piece of home also sounds
pretty nutritious as well so we've got
lots of fiber we got fat we got
micronutrients and antioxidants
so paired with the protein of your
choice
i'd say it's a pretty solid meal and i
love to travel and i find that through
food you really get a sense of the life
and the culture of a place and just from
community of cooking together of
chatting over making a meal is something
so comforting and so universal so it's
clear to me that catherine sees beyond
the buzzwords when it comes to eating
and food
like she alluded to the language of food
is universal and while north americans
are over here on tick tock worrying
about consuming watermelon on an empty
stomach and drinking alkaline water and
celery juice
the rest of the world is seeing food for
some of its amazing community building
and cultural building properties and i
really love that this interview is
bringing this to light when i was
pregnant i craved indian food every
every day i was brought up on indian
food in wales and where i come from we
have a fabulous huge indian community
indian food has been really you know
intermixed into into britain so there's
often no rhyme or reason about what
foods women will crave when they're
pregnant though comfort foods are common
and it does sound like indian cuisine
holds like a special place in
catherine's heart but also it's not
uncommon for a lot of pregnant women to
crave spicy food when they're expecting
now again we don't have any good
research to suggest why this is
some experts do believe that it either
has to do with just shifts in hormones
or
is possibly related to the body's
instinct to cool itself down since
sweating is actually our body's
self-cooling mechanism
regardless i now really really want a
curry and i'm not pregnant i hope i'm
not pregnant things i avoid to eat i
don't like awful liver kidneys all that
stuff tripe
can't do that msg i have lips that look
really pretty for about two minutes
because they're all plumped and i go wow
my lips look great it's an awful awful
reaction that i have i love to i also
don't like awful so aka orchid meat so
things like kidneys
liver sweetbreads etc
i don't know i've eaten in a lot of
fancy pants restaurants and
even though i know that they're cooked
like perfectly i just can't quite wrap
my head around them so
they're a no-go for me as for msg
i actually have a blog post that i'm
going to link below which heads-up is
sponsored so i want to be transparent
about that but i do feel strongly that
there is a lot of fear-mongering
misinformation out there about msg
some of which i think may actually have
even some racist roots in some
situations so there's that but in short
msg or monosodium glutamate is made up
of the amino acid glutamate plus sodium
and while it's often added as like a
seasoning to enhance the flavor of food
glutamate also is naturally found in
foods like corn green peas mushrooms
some cheese tomatoes even breast milk
which actually is super high in
glutamate now there are a lot of rumors
floating around about msg but some of
the big ones sent around the idea that
it causes neurological damage or even
autism now the thinking behind these
theories is that the glutamate from the
msg enters our bloodstream and then gets
into our brain
leading to neurological damage this is
actually physiologically impossible
because msg can't even cross the blood
brain barrier where it would do harm
it's also been cited that msg causes
headaches or kind of like hangover like
experiences
symptoms that are often racistly deemed
chinese restaurant syndrome
now not sure that has aged well here in
2021 but problematic moniker aside there
actually is no scientifically
established link between msg and
migraine headaches in fact the
international headache society removed
it from its list of migraine triggers in
2018. obviously i do think that all
experiences are valid so i don't want to
say no you don't get a headache when you
eat msg-related takeout but i'm just
sharing what the science says and there
is evidence actually to suggest that a
lot of those transient symptoms like
headache flushing tingling palpitations
drowsiness and numbness
aren't actually evident in most people
when they don't know they're eating msg
so this is what we call the nocebo
effect and it definitely is very real
having said that we also know that the
fda has observed that some people can in
fact experience these mild transient
symptoms though their standard for this
claim is actually a mega dose of three
grams all at once without food so to put
that into perspective to get that
equivalent in food you would have to
drink over a cup of soy sauce or eat
nine ounces of parmesan cheese i love
cheese sounds like catherine loves
cheese but that's a lot of cheese so if
msg doesn't feel good to you then by all
means please do avoid it i think we all
know our bodies best but generally
speaking i'm just stating that the
evidence does not support the common
concern that msg is poison or
universally bad for you in moderate
normal amounts now in katherine's case
specifically
it seems like her symptoms around msg
are maybe less about the g part and more
about the s
aka an excessive intake of sodium some
of us are more sensitive to large
amounts of sodium than others and
typically food that has added msg in it
is usually heavily processed or cooked
in a restaurant and therefore quite high
in added salt so it does make sense that
she's experiencing like swelling and
excessive thirst as these are common
symptoms of excess salt intake it sounds
like she's got a pretty significant
reaction so i don't know there may be
other intolerances or allergies going on
but i agree i think it's probably best
to avoid those kinds of foods if it's
causing those types of symptoms for her
ice cream was just across the board i'm
just a huge ice cream lover and of
course how can i forget my mother's
apple pie the only other great thing she
can cook coupled with a little scoop of
ice cream and i'm a really really happy
woman she's really throwing her poor mom
here under the bus for her poor cooking
skills but anyways i i'm really really
happy to hear that the woman loves a
little dessert because
all is good in the world when there's a
little slice of pie at la mode that your
mama made with love also a favorite of
mine some people say do you live to eat
or do you eat to live
i'm somewhere in between and i think
this is actually a really good place to
be
so this to me is really like a
simplified way of describing gentle
nutrition there's an appreciation of
food for its cultural social and
pleasure promoting benefits
and that sometimes like a little scoop
of ice cream serves no other purpose
than to put a smile on someone's face
and there's also some acknowledgement
through experimentation self-care and
self-reflection that maybe certain foods
fuel your body better or make you feel
better than others do
intuitive eating isn't just eat junk all
the live long day and don't give a [ __ ]
about your health
it's actually caring deeply about health
but acknowledging that health is both
physical and emotional and sometimes a
slice of mom's apple pie
is just really what's good for the soul
and now
i really want pie pie and curry it's
gonna be a really weird lunch that's for
sure but anyways on that note what can
we say about mrs jones diet well i likey
likey what i see now from what i can
glean from this short interview it
appears as though catherine eats a
variety of foods she doesn't have or
create fear around certain foods or food
groups is in tune with what feels good
to her body she honors her cravings and
all around has a really great
relationship with food it seems like
she's effectively and effortlessly found
a place where she can both eat for
pleasure and that familial social
experience as well as eat based on what
feels best to her body and even though
there are a few minor diet reference
offenses
i feel comfortable and inspired
listening to her talk about food i'm not
sure if this is wisdom that one
accumulates with age or if after a
certain amount of time in la you just
kind of say life is too short to drink
celery juice and fast but either way i
want more of this and less of that in my
social media feeds so guys that was all
for today i hope you enjoyed this video
a big thank you to nordvpn for
sponsoring if you liked it don't forget
to give it the thumbs up leave me a
comment below on your thoughts today or
who you'd like to see me review next
subscribe to the channel and i'll see
you next time on abby's kitchen bye
you